Fill in the blanks to
complete the equation.
So they have 76,830 is
equal to 6 ten thousands
plus blank thousands plus
8 hundreds plus 3 tens.
So let's just
think about 76,830.
So if we write 76,830-- I'm
going to try to color-code it.
We could write this out as
being the same thing as 70,000
plus 6,000-- the 7 is in
the ten thousands place.
So it's 7 ten thousands,
which is 70,000, plus-- the 6
is in the thousands place--
so it's 6,000, or 6 thousands,
one could say, plus 800.
Or you could say 8 hundreds.
800 plus 3 tens, or 30.
And then there's 0
ones, so we could just
write that out as 0 if we like.
Now, what we have
on the right here
is almost what they have
on the right over here.
Notice the 0.
They didn't write that.
So we can ignore that.
The 0 really doesn't
affect the value.
We have 3 tens.
Let me do this in a
color you can see.
You have 8 hundreds.
You have 800.
But then that's where
it starts to break down.
They have blank thousands.
Here we have 6 thousands.
So we're going to have to
think about this a little bit.
And then they have 6 ten
thousands, which is 60,000.
Here we have 70 thousands.
So we've got to work
through these two places
right over here.
So they have 6 ten
thousands, which
is the same thing as 60,000.
We have 70,000.
So they essentially
took 10,000 from here
and regrouped it someplace.
And since these two
places are the same,
they must have regrouped it
into the thousands place.
So let's try to do that.
So let's get rid of
10,000 out of the 70,000.
It becomes 60,000.
So this becomes a 6.
And then we're regrouping
that into the thousands place.
So we're going to add 10,000
to the thousands place.
Now what's the thousands
place going to be then?
Well, it's 10,000 plus 6,000.
It's going to
become 16 thousands.
This right over here is
going to become a 16.
So now what we wrote
here looks just
like what they wrote up here.
This is 6 ten thousands
plus 16 thousands
plus 8 hundreds plus 3 tens.
And we're done.